Friends with Brews.
Well, I'm awake. My ears, I'm awake. And hello. How's it going, Scott?
This is exciting because although we've had Adam Bell on this podcast as a guest several times, we've never had a guest plus not had Peter.
So Peter's now hearing me say I'm very excited that we're not having Peter, but we're not having Peter. We're having John Chidgey.
Well, thanks for having me.
And you, you're a real coffee aficionado. You're not drinking that decaf stuff that Peter always drinks.
Ew, what? No. I mean I have, okay, I have aspirational decaf that I imagine I may drink at some point.
It's just sitting there waiting for me to drink it. And it's been sitting there for a while.
Which means it's probably not good to drink it at this point.
So, I think like I say, it's aspirational decaf. It's there.
I just, yeah.
The decaf starts off inferior and then of course, like any coffee, the longer it sits, the more inferior it gets.
Yeah, exactly. So I'm probably scared to touch it. It's been sitting there for a couple years now. So but that's okay
It's aspirational and speaking of that. What are you drinking this morning? So all this evening? Sorry, I
Am drinking a local coffee roasters
they're called back porch coffee and they have a blend called the back porch blend and
It is quite good. It's got
Dark chocolate peanut butter orange citrus in it and it's really good. We can talk about
Methodologies here if you want to I use a collie to wave and I do a pour over which I like because of the process of
It I don't know. It's just something I enjoy doing it is harder to get the same smoothness as the
What's the plunger thing that you use?
Arrow press. Yeah, the arrow press arrow press is number one for getting just a smooth with no acidity and no bitterness
But I also have to use double the grounds to get the strength of the coffee
I want with the AeroPress. So I use a Kalita Wave, but with this one it's pretty easy to
make it nice and smooth and not at all bitter. So I really like this blend, this roast.
Nice.
What about you?
Well I'm stepping out of my comfort zone and mainly because I ran out of coffee.
So normally I'll get a half a kilo or you know one kilo bag of beans. It's good for like three weeks,
you know, for me having a couple of cups of coffee in the morning.
and normally I have my favorite Campos superior blend done as an espresso but I do that, I'm
froth up some milk and make myself a latte out of it but if I have more time I will either use an
AeroPress or I'll use my Hario V60 pour over. So it depends on the sort of mood I'm in and how much
time I have. As odd as it sounds and I guess maybe it's not odd because the whole point of the
espresso machine originally was to make coffee more quickly so it is in fact quicker to make a
coffee using the espresso machine. But in any case, depends on the mood I'm in. And so anyway,
that would have been all well and good. But the Campos Superior blend I'd run out. So when I was
out in the shops yesterday, I grabbed something randomly and I hate to admit it, I was drawn in
by the packaging. This particular one I've never tried it before. It's called The Darkness. And
yeah, it's rich and chocolatey apparently, which I kind of taste the richness, the chocolatey bit
as a stretch and it's by a company called DC Roasters. So they're an Australian, you know,
roaster and they're based in Victoria but they ship their stuff all around Australia. And this
particular one's a mixture of Colombian, two parts of Brazil, Armenia Brazil, Labarida,
Labarida? I don't know how to pronounce that. And South Silvestri. So they've got an interesting
blend in here and some of it's quite dark roasted and you can taste that bitterness.
It rates itself on a scale of one to ten of intensity of an eight out of ten, whatever that even means.
Would I say it's intense? I'd say it's a little bit more bitter.
And that's probably because it was done as an espresso shot. It really brought that acidity out.
But having said that, it's smooth.
And it is a bit of a slap in your face kind of a coffee, which is kind of what I need in the morning.
Not too bad. Not too bad at all.
That's interesting. I am looking at the packaging and I have to admit, see,
here in the US, for roasters and even honestly beers that would have this crazy of a package,
I would generally shy away from it because they're usually going for a super strong effect that I don't necessarily want.
So I looked at this and I immediately got scared. And not just because of the skulls on the package, but...
It does draw your eye, doesn't it? Because there you are walking down the aisle and you can get something like a standard Vittoria coffee,
kind of like an Albany brown colored packet.
And then you see this bright green glowing thing
with skulls on it.
And you're like, "Oh yeah, I'll have a go at that."
So I sucked in by the marketing.
Sucked in by the marketing.
But yeah, I don't know if I'd get it again
because I, like you, don't necessarily like
the super strong as a regular thing.
I'm like, it's nice for a change for me,
but I prefer the Campos because it's not as roasted as dark.
Yeah, I don't get the whole full city roast thing.
Sorry, Marco.
But yeah.
Yeah, so when you use your Hario, that's basically equivalent to using the Kalita Wave.
I mean, there's people that like either one.
I don't have strong feelings either way because I haven't used the Hario.
To me, it could have been one or the other.
I just happened to go with the Kalita Wave.
But when do you choose to do one over the other?
So when I want to have a black coffee, I will always use the Hario
simply because it doesn't make it really bitter.
And if I do an AeroPress, it is still--
I find AeroPress is still more bitter than a pour over.
Oh, interesting.
Yeah, just my taste buds, I don't know.
That's just what I found.
But the funny thing is when I'm traveling, though, I'll always take the AeroPress.
I just find it easier to work with when I'm traveling.
So, for example, I spent five days in Monto, which is a little country town,
about five or six hours drive from here in north and west from Brisbane.
And they don't have, well, they're a country town, so they're not open.
nothing's open on a Sunday and their coffee shops are barely open on Saturday
morning. So if you want a coffee, it's a BYO thing on the weekend.
So I brought my AeroPress and pre-ground some coffee and it was actually pretty
damn good to be honest. So, but yeah, I'll use the Hari-Up,
I want a black coffee, no milk whatsoever. And I do that from time to time. Yeah.
It's the sort of thing though, that I've got to be in the mood and I gotta,
I gotta have more time to do it. So generally I'll do it on a Sunday morning.
It's a process.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. And one of the things I love about coffee is that, you know,
The way you make it has a massive impact on how it tastes.
And whilst I do drink lattes quite a bit, it's not the only way I enjoy coffee.
And I think that's wonderful about coffee, to be honest, because with tea, it's like you just
dug a tea bag or put tea leaves in hot water and that's it.
It's like, great.
That is true, but it's interesting, like if you get some of the tea leaves, if you get it in
leaf format, you'll find that different tea vendors for a specific tea will recommend
wildly different water temperatures and wildly different times for steeping.
>> That's true.
>> It really depends, and to be honest, I'm not super great at brewing tea, so I couldn't
tell you what the differences are when I take a tea and do it exactly the way they want
to versus not exactly the way they want to.
I really need to drink a lot more tea.
My problem is, for some reason, although I have patience for doing the pour over coffee method, I don't know, doing the tea bugs me.
Tea seems to want to be at lower temperature.
And by the time I get it brewed and by the time I get through what's in the pot, it's too cool already.
I don't know. I got to figure out a better way.
I don't want to pay for one of those tea robots just yet, but maybe someday I'll have to.
Well, what was transformative for me for both the tea and for the pour over
was getting a, what is it, Brewista kettle.
That'sSo you set the temperature and away you go and it's got a keep warm function.
It's fantastic. And so my wife takes herYeah.
So, you know, have you got one or something similar?
Yeah, I've got a basically, probably a slightly cheaper version of something that does exactly the same thing.
Yeah. Yeah. All right.
Awesome. Yeah. So my wife, for example, she likes her black teas and black teas are generally done at 98
or 100 depending upon the recommendation, like you say, some of them are, they want them to be hotter
and you know the extra two degrees can make a difference. Anyway when I'm doing the pour overs
on the Aeropress I'll set it lower than that and so on and so forth but and the the whole
gooseneck thing which I originally you know sort of like scoffed at it just makes it so much easier
when you're doing a pour over to control that flow rate and as well as even in the Aeropress I found
Because using a stout pourer on the one at the pub I was staying at, was difficult to get that
even and right. Because I found that the water flow rushed down the side and sort of like blew
out straight down to the aeropress filter and then the water just went straight through without
actually soaking the grounds. And I'm like, this wouldn't have happened if I had my
my goose neck. But never mind. Anyway. Yeah, it's either pouring straight through or it's
just churning the grinds like crazy.
Yeah, exactly.
And you just... anyway.
But yeah, you're right.
The steeping time and the steeping and the temperature are two of the variables with tea.
And I have learnt via my wife more than myself because she'll tell me,
"Oh, that was a good cup." I'm like, "Yep, noted for future reference."
So I've gotten better at not oversteeping tea,
which is something, a mistake I used to make.
Has it been steeping for 20 minutes?
Eh, it's long enough.
No, it's probably too long.
Too long.
Besides, centuries of Japanese tea ceremonies tell me that some people do think that there's an art to brewing tea.
So, totally.
I can't argue with them. They're the experts.
All right. Hey, John, since the last time I talked to you in person or yeah, I think so.
I think that you and I both have new computer equipment.
I think we both have new Macs. Is that true?
I think so. Well, you tell me about yours and then I'll tell you about mine.
Okay, well, I bought a 2021 MacBook Pro 14 inch with an M1 Pro.
It's the base model, except I got the terabyte of storage.
Nice.
So it was affordable and I could justify it.
But I was famously a laptop hater before.
And all of the things that I hated about laptops are pretty much gone.
The noise, the heat, the compromise, performance, all that stuff's gone.
The Apple Silicon made such a remarkable transformation of what it's like to use a laptop.
This is the best Mac I've ever owned by far, and I've owned some desktop Macs. I've even owned the
old Intel cheese grater Mac Pros in the past. But this thing is amazing. It just scythes through
whatever I throw at it without the fans spinning up at all. It's pretty remarkable.
Yeah, they're a very nice machine and Apple Silicon has changed the game,
Absolutely. And I love my Mac Pro 2013. I also had a cheese grater before that, a 2009 Quad
Core Nihalem Mac Pro, which, to be honest, it was a beast both in size and in power and consumption
and heat production. I mean, that thing was just a beautiful machine, but you could walk into the
study and you could feel the five to 10 degrees of temperature rising as you walked into the room.
I think it was a space heater. Even though it wasn't trying to be, that's what it was,
and because those Intel's just kick out so much heat. And my 2013 trashcan Mac Pro,
which I used for one and a half years during the worst of COVID, I picked it up secondhand,
and it was a beautiful machine. And I was running a whole bunch of virtual machines,
running Alpine Linux and all sorts of stuff on it. So I did that on top of using it for day-to-day
work, and it just, it very rarely had any issues. It was a beautiful machine. And then Apple Silicon
came out and I needed a machine that could drive my three 4k displays that I became slightly addicted
to during Covid as well because I used to have the laptop screen and one external display then
that became a 4k display then that became two external 4k displays and then I'm like right
I really want a more powerful desktop so I ended up getting myself a Mac Studio. So the Mac Studio
is so much better quieter like the power consumption I checked in the Mac Pro at idle
was 137 watts average, whereas the Maxx Studio at idle doesn't even crack 50 watts.
And it's just... just...
Okay.
It's next level.
And it is so quiet.
The fans on it.
I mean, you can hear that crow in the background telling us what it thinks.
But you can't hear the fans on this thing.
You just can't.
Even though they're spinning away at 1300 RPM, you can't hear them.
And there's no power supply noise or anything like that.
It's just beautifully quiet.
>> JONATHAN VON VAN VEN: Yeah, that would have definitely been the way I was going to
go if I had gone with a desktop Mac again.
I came to the conclusion that I was done with the iPad as a working device experiment that
I had been conducting for a couple years for many reasons, and I don't want to get into
it here.
That's not a topic I want to dive into today.
But the bottom line is I decided I'm tired of fighting with the iPad Pro's operating
system to do the things that I need to do and always just barely falling short.
I mean, it excelled at some things, but the funny thing is is that, okay, I said I wasn't
going to talk about it, but the narrative around the iPad is, "Oh, it can't do this,
it can't do that," but usually when people say that, it can do the things that they think
it can't.
It does fall short in other areas, but it's usually not what people think it is, and it
would be more like the Federicos of the world who could tell you where it actually crashes
and falls short.
But anyway, I got tired of bumping up against those, and I decided, "Okay, I can afford
one Mac, so I'm going with a laptop and Clay and Vic had talked to me enough to convince me that
this is a laptop that I won't hate.
It's not going to feel like the noisy thing that you can't stand to use because it's burning a hole
in your pants or blowing fans or it's slow because it's overheating.
And so that's why I went with that.
But the Mac Studio, I think, is an amazing computer.
It really looks nice.
And that that attempted me at first.
Yeah, it's honestly been the fastest, quietest and best desktop Mac I've ever had.
And then the situation at work required me to be going into the office more regularly with
the tail end of COVID, so I then invested in an M.2 MacBook Air. And the only upgrade I did on that
was I got a 512GB SSD because I just could not handle 256GB. Same with the Mac Studio, I went to
to a one terabyte SSD as opposed to the 512 stock.
So, but other than that, they're both entry-level models.
Yeah, 'cause I needed a laptop for work
'cause the laptops that they give you at work
but from the IT department are just as bad
as they always were.
And the thing is I went through the catalogs
and on the online IT ordering service portal
and said, I want a high-performance laptop.
Well, their high-performance laptop runs probably
quarter of the speed of my MacBook Air. So yeah, for sure.
It's not even a race. It's not a contest. It's just a joke. So I'm like, yeah, okay.
Anyway, so I've also got myself a MacBook Air.
It's the two fantastic machines.
And now that I've got something like the Mac Studio
running Final Cut Pro and doing editing for the from the YouTube channel has become
really, really easy.
Yeah, that's cool. That's awesome.
Yeah, I have a similar thing with my work laptop except surprisingly, John, I recently,
well, I don't remember, a few months ago they upgraded my computer at work and I have a Lenovo
T14 and I actually really like it. It does bog down occasionally and it does churn through
battery like crazy. Those are two huge differences between it and my MacBook Pro, but that was the
computer that convinced me that I would be okay with the 14-inch form factor because I've always
thought I need the biggest laptop possible and I had a 16 inch laptop at work before that.
I really like the 14 inch form factor and on the MacBook Pro it's just about perfect for me.
It's got a beautiful enough screen with small enough bezels that I can see what I need to see,
plus when I'm at the desk I have it plugged into a studio display anyway. But
yeah, it's that form factor I could not be happier with. I really like it. So I'm glad that I got that
that computer at work before I decided which Mac to buy because it did convince
me to go with the 14 inch.
Yeah, I actually, I did seriously consider the MacBook Pros and I could have
stretched and got a MacBook Pro if I wanted to.
But by that time I'd got, I'd prioritized the Mac Studio.
And so that kind of ate away my budget and I was like, yeah, okay,
so now I've got MacBook Air money as opposed to MacBook Pro money.
So I sort of, yeah, that sort of made my decision for me.
was my previous choice from a month a month and a bit prior. But for me, I guess I looked at it like this.
If you want to have a laptop/desktop sort of thing that you take everywhere and as your machine,
then you have one desktop-like machine or laptop-like, you know,
you definitely go for a MacBook Pro. And I also think the 14-inch form factor is better than the larger one.
I hate big laptops because they're too... to me, it's about portability.
So the bigger the laptop the more cumbersome it is. I used to own 15 inch MacBook Pros way back in the day
I never owned it 17, but for me the 17 inch was comical
Yeah, and I just couldn't even and even the 15 inch after a while it got a bit too much
So I've been you know 13 inch laptop owner ever since I never went smaller than that to the 11
I ever tried an 11 because I felt too cramped
But the 14 maintains approximately the dimensions of the 13 and yet the screen is that much bigger. I can absolutely see its appeal
>> Yeah, and they're a lot lighter than they used to be.
I used to have some of those way back in the day.
I had a couple 15-inch MacBook Pros also, and those were pretty heavy.
Those were heavy beasts.
>> For sure, definitely.
>> Well, if you or any of the listeners out there have been listening to this podcast,
you'll know that I don't know why, but Peter has fallen in love with chatGPT.
I thought the whole AI thing was an interesting topic, and I thought that chatGPT was...
It's like cryptocurrency.
It's like that all over again, where you've got people that are skeptical and you've got
some people that just can't see anything but the upsides to it.
And it's been a pretty fascinating look at how we really haven't learned a whole lot
in terms of our stance on technology.
It seems like we still have a lot of people that are 100%, "This is only good, this is
great," and some people that are 100% skeptical, and then a few people in between.
And I really enjoyed a podcast I listened to recently.
There's a podcast called Tech Won't Save Us.
They look at tech from a different angle.
They look at it from the lens of the people who create these things and think they're
transforming the world generally aren't, or they are, but in a bad way, not the way that
they claim they are.
And the woman that was on this, I'll probably pronounce her name wrong, but Timnit Gebru,
She's an AI expert and she was working at Google and she actually got fired from Google
when she was trying to build up a committee and a group, a working group in Google that
would make sure that AI was being used responsibly and that all of the inbuilt prejudices and
all of the inherent social problems that come from AI being designed the way it is designed
would be addressed and looked at.
And I guess at some point Google didn't really want to hear it.
And so I listened to that and it got me thinking a lot about some of these things.
And then of course looking at some of the issues that ChatGBT has had, like with CNET
trying to use it to write articles with, and it turns out, "Hey, gee, they're full of mistakes
and errors.
Who knew?"
And then artists who are suing AI image generators for using their names as keywords, in other
words, using their work as inputs to the AI to train their models and so forth without their
permission. And I just thought, I kind of wanted to get an impression of what your views on this
whole thing are, you know, what your view is with respect to the strengths, the weaknesses,
the good things, the bad things. How do you feel about the hype, I guess?
First of all, I haven't actually been able to get onto ChatGPT to have a play with it,
because it's at capacity. They said, "Oh, well, we'll let you know when it's available again."
And I'm like, yeah, great. And still waiting.
And that was weeks ago.
Yeah.
Because I was vaguely aware of it.
I've been listening to a bunch of different podcasts and read a bunch of articles about it.
So this is not firsthand use.
But to be honest, I think I've seen enough of here's the input.
This is the output, you know,
comparatives for me to have some opinion of it, but I just need to state that up front.
Before I sort of like go into that, do you remember a program many, many years ago?
perhaps the first so-called AI program, ELISA, the therapist program. Do you remember that?
Yeah, I do.
So ELISA, the way it worked is it took your questions and it essentially broke them down
into their constituent components and then rephrased them as a question where it could,
but there was also a random generator that would ask things like, could you elaborate more on that?
Or, you know, how did that make you feel where it could not do that? And it was very, very basic.
the code behind it was really not that complicated, but it created the illusion of interactivity,
like, oh hey, I'm having a conversation with a computer, this is like, this is artificial
intelligence, it's going to take over the world, and once you learn how it works, it's like the
veil is lifted and you're like, yeah okay, so this is fun, but it's not actually useful,
like it really, really is not useful, but it's fun and it's cool, but it's really not useful, and so
My take on ChatGPT is that it's the ELISA, but with machine learning.
It's more or less the same kind of, "Hey, this is really cool. Isn't this amazing? Yeah. Is it useful?
No. No, not really." And the problem is that the data that it gives you is only good as the data
that you feed into it, like any machine learning model. Machine learning is based on just pattern
recognition, repetition, identification of information within patterns. And so ultimately,
if you feed it garbage, you will get garbage. And the thing is that I, because having looked
at what's happened to the internet, you know, my entire life, it started out with that promise
of being, oh, it's free information, information is free, everyone can get access to all this
information. It'll be great. It'll be like, you can have an encyclopedia and you'll be able to
search for anything and you'll just get the answer online. It's going to be amazing. And in many ways
that is true, but the problem is that it's also, and I mean I know that disinformation is kind of
like one of those catch terms at the moment, but the opposite of truth or of reality can also be
posted just as equally alongside, and in some cases weighted as equally, as something that is
an established fact. If you look at the way that they would research encyclopedia articles in the
past, they were way way more thorough than anything on the internet generally speaking today.
Like, you know, Wikipedia is another great example, you know, citation needed kind of BS that goes back,
you know, that argument's been going on for a decade or more.
So I sort of feel like the problem with any machine learning algorithm is if you have a pure source of data to feed it,
that is, first of all, you're legally allowed to use it, and second of all, it is a true representative sample of reality,
whatever that might be, then you will get meaningful useful information out of it.
But if you think about that, that's actually not possible.
If you're using anything on the internet as your source of data, you are going to have random BS in there,
and therefore your outputs will occasionally be random BS.
And I just look at ChatTPT just from that point of view, we'll talk about the whole image thing in a minute,
but I guess I just look at that and I think to myself, "Well, sure, this is cool,
but you can't trust the answers because it's probably anywhere from 5 to 99% BS."
I think you're absolutely right. Anything, whether it be a chat AI or whether it be art generation...
Art generation's a little different because it can come up with things that aren't meant to be
true or false, or they're not meant to be narratively correct. They just are.
But at the same time, still with those, people have found, like for example, Asian women who
have used AI image generators have found that those AI image generators want to undress them
or put them in skimpy clothing more often than they do with other people.
And so they're subject to the Asian woman fetish that exists on the internet, and that goes into
those AI image generators, and that's what they output. Yeah, I remember, John, I'm sure we're both
old enough to remember when we first started on this tech roller coaster, when personal
computers first started becoming a thing, and then it became the internet.
I felt really optimistic about it all.
It felt like it could only be a good thing.
Of course, now, since then, there's been many times where I've wondered if the internet
was just a giant mistake.
Yeah, I can't get along without it because there's so many things I researched and so
many things I learned that would be so much more difficult to do without the internet.
But looking at the state of humanity and how some of our social problems are undoubtedly
caused by everybody having access to everybody else's thoughts, and some people's brains aren't
capable of handling that because they'll believe any terrible sounding thing that they hear,
it does make you wonder. And then to dump all of that into AIs that don't know what reality is and
have no way to... they're even worse than the people falling for conspiracy theories on Facebook in
terms of falsehood rejection, in my opinion, because they just have no clue to begin with.
Yeah. The thing that I find interesting about machine learning is that people equate machine
machine learning with human intelligence.
And we can recognize things like you say, you know, like to go the whole
Silicon Valley on you, like, you know, hot dog, not hot dog kind of thing.
So I can tell the difference between something that's a hot dog and it's not
a hot dog, but, you know, so can a machine learning algorithm.
But in the future, let's say that this hot dog now that comes
in three different subtypes and so on and so forth.
And the original thing we used to call
hot dog is no longer called a hot dog, you could teach a human, you know, hey,
this thing you used to call a hot dog, it's now going to be called something else. And you know,
like a hoagie, I don't know, I'm picking a random American slang name for something and I'm probably
getting that wrong, doesn't matter. But the point is that a human being can relearn that and say,
you know what, I'm not going to call that anymore, maybe I'll slip into bad habits every now and then
and call it what I used to call it, but I can sort of train myself, I can learn a different way,
or different thing, a different way of identifying something. And you know, machine learning
algorithms, like it's how you teach them to unlearn something that they've been trained on
is extremely difficult. And at this point in time, the simplest way to do it is to wipe it and start
over with a different data set. And that doesn't include the thing that you don't want in it
anymore. And that's not the way a human works, because a human will be, well, what are we going
to do? Wipe your memory and start you out as a toddler? And we're going to train you again?
This is no longer a hot dog. I mean, that's, humans don't work like that. We don't need to work like
that. We can change our thinking. We can, you know, it's, I don't know, in many
respects, I've just, I've been listening to the whole machine learning is the
future and everything and there's a whole bunch of stuff that it can do.
That's for sure and it is very cool but it will never be on its own in isolation
as a technology. It will never be adaptive. It will never be at the same level that
a human can be simply because all it is is patent recognition and you've got to
see that for what it is and all of its faults.
So it's not it's not the cure all for all of our for all of our ills, that's for sure.
Right. And sometimes it is really hard to change a human's mind, but humans can change
your minds. And we and we see over time, like, you know, just think about yourself and I
can think about myself and over time, how much my thought processes about specific
topics have changed as I've just realized, oh, I had a very naive, shallow view of this
topic and I didn't know what it was like from this other person's point of view.
And I think, you know, everybody, you try to keep learning, you try to keep getting
better, but I don't think there's any way to give machine learning that
understanding of, like, humans can have a collective understanding of, "Oh, this is
the way we should be headed if we want a better society." Machine learning will
take all those inputs and I don't know how it makes a judgment on, "Well, I need
to be careful about this because these people clearly have some sort of motive
for pushing this theory. Like we know that anytime somebody's trying to sell you something,
there's a reason. It might be good, it might be bad, but there is a reason when people
are trying to sell you stuff. And it doesn't matter if it's a product or a thought process
or a belief system or whatever it is, people are trying to convince you to believe something
for a reason. I don't know how you teach AI or computers to understand that they have
to figure that out and weed out the preconceptions and the prejudices behind the information
they're being fed. I don't see how that's possible.
Exactly. I think that's a difficult problem and machine learning unlearning is actually a
field of study in machine learning spheres and they claim that they are making progress.
But I couldn't find anything recently on it. I did a little bit of a research before we started
recording and I can't see anything recently on it. It's difficult. But it's not just unlearning
when it learns the wrong thing or takes in data that it shouldn't, that may not be true.
it's also things like hallucination. And I originally, when I heard the term AI hallucination,
I'm like, that's okay, well they're giving some magic mushrooms to the AI, interesting.
But it's actually fooling the machine learning pattern matching to think that something is what
it isn't. And so like, for example, arranging certain objects and images on a sign or putting
stickers on a sign to make it look like it's a stop sign when it isn't, you know, things like that.
Whereas a human might look at that sign and say, well, that's clearly not a stop sign.
And someone's just put a sticker on it because we can separate out,
like out of the broad field of our view, we know exactly what a stop sign looks like in the context
of I'm driving a car, it's on the side of the road, I'm looking at this sign, is that a stop sign?
Whereas a machine learning algorithm looks at the entirety and says, well, this is the pattern that
I've recognized previously as a stop sign. It doesn't matter if I'm on a road or anywhere.
It has no way of having additional depth and context to determine, oh, hang on,
on, that's a sticker on top of a sign, it's not actually what the sign actually says.
It has no way of, it can't do that. So tricking AI is, that's the term they're calling
AI hallucination. But the whole thing is, it's problematic. And I guess the other thing
is I want to just quickly address is the whole, you know, artists thing. The funny thing I
was thinking about is that like artists, I'm okay, I'm not an artist, not really. I've
I've done a few logos that were mostly terrible and I can't paint to save my life.
It basically looks like a big, it's like grey smudgy mess when I'm done.
And that in itself is not art as far as I'm concerned.
So I'm not an artist.
Well, you are a photographer and that's an artistic workflow.
It's not that you're using your fingers or your hands to move in certain ways to generate
your art, but photography is very much an art form.
So you get the mindset.
Oh, okay.
Okay, yeah, I accept that. That's fair. And even for years, Scott, I didn't see myself as a photographer.
But the more I've been doing it and the more I've invested in it, the more I've learned about it,
the more I realize that I'm starting to think more like an artist when I'm setting up for a photo.
I'm still a far cry from, you know, some of the professionals, that's for sure.
And I'll probably never get to that point because I have other things in my life.
But okay, fine. I accept that. Fair comment.
The artist mindset is, well, the way art works is we start by mimicry.
and we say, well, I really respect this kind of art.
I want to make art just like this.
And then, you know, as time goes on and we, you know, we learn more
and we absorb more and we look around more, we try a few things.
And it's like, well, I really like doing it this way.
This one thing I particularly like about it.
So I'm going to go off on a tangent.
I'm going to do this my way.
And then, you know, they talk about having the artist's own voice.
You know, they find their own voice, their own style, their own
way of conveying what they want to in their art.
And it's like that is then becomes unique
because that is then unique to that individual,
rather you hope that it is.
So you apply that context now to an AI system
that's trying to auto-generate art for you.
And you think to yourself,
well, it's a similar kind of a process,
but the only difference is that the AI is not going to say,
well, there's one particular thing that I like,
and I'm just gonna go off on a bit of a tangent here
and have my own voice.
It's not capable of doing that.
So it's basically art,
but it can only ever be a combination
of the sum of its inputs. So whatever you put into it is all you will ever get out of
it in a weird mishmash in the output. And that sort of thing is probably okay for a
lot of people that don't, and this is going to sound really, I don't know actually how
this sounds, but people that really understand and can interpret art, and like I say, that's
why it sounds weird, is because to me, appreciating art is in some ways as difficult as creating
art. Because for example, like I would, before I was a photographer, I'd walk down like in a photo
gallery and I'd say, well, there's a bunch of photos there. Yep, that's a bridge. Yep, that's
a house. And that's a person. Good. Whereas now I'd walk down exactly the same row of photos and
I'd stop and I'd say, oh my God, look at the way that they've matched the light and the angle and
how did they do that? And I'm like, yeah, I can truly appreciate difficult photos because I know
how hard it is to take them. So average person will just say, "Hey, that's a nice photo of a bridge."
So you type in your AI thing, it spits out a logo of a car driving on, you know, on sand or something
like that, I don't know, and you'll look at that and you'll say, "Well, I'm not an artist, but it's
good enough, right?" But the truth is that that's all that can ever be, and you'll never get anything
beyond that. You'll never get anything that is really artistic in the sense of the way a human
can create art by finding their own voice. So, I mean, this is probably a very engineering
take on AI from the point of view of, like, will an AI ever develop its own voice for
creating art based on everything else that's put into it? And I genuinely don't think it
can. And that comes back to the debate of AI being soulless and the nature of a soul
and blah blah blah, free will and choice and yadda yadda yadda. But I mean, I don't know
if that's just a rambling mess of thoughts there, probably is.
No, no, no. I agree with you, and I think that it's interesting because Jason Snell was talking
about finding the same thing with respect to writing. He's going, "Well, you can tell that
it was just, you know, fed a bunch of, you know, bad internet stories, and it wasn't given the good
literature and all that." But you're right in that it's not going to develop its own voice. And the
one thing I took away from Peter's super long narration of his chat GPT experiment, trying to
to get it to write a story for him was that it would come up with something, he would
disagree with the premise, he would say "but wait, that can't be because blah blah blah"
and it would say "oh, you're right!" it basically was a yes man, I mean it has no opinion, it
has no idea, it has no creative expression, it has nothing but what it's given and then
it just goes along with that so... it can generate things, I mean CNET tried to replace
writers with it and I'm sure other places have too, and I suppose you could have it
generate certain types of writing, but they're never going to be a writer that people say...
If you have a... You can't replace a Jason Snell or a John Gruber with an AI, for example,
and that's just taking tech writing. That's not even taking creative writing, like sci-fi authors
or fantasy authors or something like that. Okay, you can teach a chat GPT to write terrible fantasy.
Those aren't the books that people want to buy. No. I guess I'm not worried about creative writers
is getting replaced by AI.
I think one of the things you just pointed out there
is that people, that you're right there,
I did read an article and I didn't keep the link
of some places that were saying,
I'm gonna use some chat GBT and AI to actually,
not chat GBT, but we're gonna use AI
to replace writers and so on and so forth.
And the thought that occurred to me is that,
but we've already got that.
It's just not an AI thing necessarily.
We have algorithms that scrape.
So for example, let's say you wanna do,
look at a review on a new camera
and you do a search in Google and the Google search comes up with this result, you go and level this result
and it's like, this camera has a large 24.5 megapixel sensor, it is black in color
and it has a rubberized hand grip and what you're doing is you're basically reading
a fake review which has essentially been computer generated based on a scraping of the tech specs
for that camera and I've come across these from time to time and I'm like they all read much the same
And it's all because it's generated by a series of algorithms that scrape the features off of a website and create a garbage review page
And it's obvious because there's nothing in there that's beyond the basic text and specs
It'll say like this item is heavy and it'll say whatever the weight is and you think to yourself
Would we call that heavy? So I feel like that has already happened and
It's already terrible and AI tools aren't really gonna make it any less terrible
it's still gonna suck and people are just gonna move on to a page where put someone who's actually picked up the camera and actually
Used it and and a lot of people will probably just turn as they already are to YouTube
For those sorts of reviews because it'll be like right. Well, you know trying an AI this right, but I guess that's probably next
Yeah. Yeah, I don't know. I initially my thought was I don't think writers and artists have anything to worry about
Apparently that's not true if it was BuzzFeed that we were that we were thinking of I found an article
Oh yeah, right, right, right.
So I guess certain types of authors may have to worry about that kind of thing, but those
websites are the types of sites that just want to churn out tons of content per day.
And let's be honest, between their headlines and a lot of the content of the articles,
which going back to what you were talking about, research, research, what's that?
Who does that anymore?
So yeah, those people need jobs and I get that, but that's the type of thing that AI
is going to come for, at least initially, unless it improves dramatically.
Those are the types of jobs that I think that you might
prospectively lose.
We'll see what happens with BuzzFeed.
We'll see if anybody.
I don't know, man. Do you want to?
I don't know.
I guess we'll have to see if people like that or not.
Well, I think that that's a self-solving problem, honestly, Scott,
because I don't read BuzzFeed.
I can't remember the last time I actively in action. No, I just.
But let's say it wasn't just they're just the first.
Like, let's say 90% of news sites say, "Let's use AI to generate summaries of things that
are going on for us."
And let's say it becomes widespread that way.
It's still going to be a certain type of article, but it's also going to let us find out whether
or not humans are okay with that, or if they even notice, I guess.
I don't know.
It's like, do I personally want to read stuff that's generated by AI?
No, not really.
Not for more than a laugh.
And even that, I don't want to keep doing it over and over.
But I don't know, maybe people will accept this.
So maybe that type of quick, generate many articles per day stuff with fancy headlines
that gets clicks, maybe that kind of stuff will go 100% AI.
I don't know.
But I can't see it being used for anything more substantial than that.
I guess I feel like a lot of this is going to be a self-solving problem and it's going
to implode because if so many people just shift across and say, "I don't need humans,
We're gonna use AI and ML to develop our articles and so on. People will simply get jack of it
and I will not read it. They will not engage and
so we go back to word-of-mouth again. We go back to I don't trust any of these websites on the internet
They're all full of it
and I can't get an honest review about anything on here because it's all fake
which to be quite honest if you look at reviews on on Amazon or
pick your platform, yeah, you got to wonder just how much you can trust them in the first place
So I still feel like a lot of this has been a gradual erosion whether or not this is the end of it or not
I don't know only truly gullible people that are not interested in actually finding out
Reality would fall for it. And and I I know honestly don't think that's very many people
I think people will just vote with their feet people are smart enough to know the difference and they will simply say you know what?
This is everything's all samey samey because it's all written by the same AI system and it's all BS. I can't trust it
so I'm not gonna read it anymore." And then, you know, page views will drop, you know,
advertising revenue will dry up, and everyone will say, "Well, what went wrong with our lives?"
And it's like, well, you know, you made a bad choice.
But the problem is, 30% of America apparently doesn't care about reality or verification of
information. I mean, I think you could replace Facebook with AI, and the people that are still
on Facebook using it all the time and who are reading conspiracy theories, you know,
they're using it for that type of thing, yelling angrily about social issues or whatever based on
some political viewpoint, I don't think they would notice or care. They already believe these dodgy
sources that have been misproven, but the problem is, once the lie is out there, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if it's proven false or not. People have already heard it, they've already
believed it, and I don't... I think there's a lot of people that honestly wouldn't know or tell the
difference or care. I don't know. I guess maybe because I've seen what's happened to the United
States over the past few years, I'm not as optimistic about it.
Well, when you say 30%, it's an oddly specific percentage. But I mean, I can't comment on that.
And I would simply point out that Facebook is dying. And whether or not and people have been
getting together for years with secret sort of, you know, groups and so on and enjoying conspiracy
theories. And I mean, you know, there's, there's a bunch of people in Australia that, you know,
don't recognize the government and all that other stuff and
Yada yada yada. I mean it's everywhere just that's just human nature people have a right to believe what they want to believe
There's a multiplier effect though when it's when they have such easily gotten to and easily
You know registered for sites and locations that keep actively generating stuff that purposely stokes their emotions
I do agree with you that that's just human
But I also think that Silicon Valley is giving them a multiplier effect that has made the problem substantially worse
I won't disagree with that statement in
Yeah in that regard. I think ultimately Silicon Valley has a lot to answer for and a lot of things
regarding social media and the social media experiment and so on and and I look at things like the feta versus being a
Far more balanced way of dealing with the problem
But having said that it's still susceptible to people starting their own things like truth or maybe no truth social or whatever the heck it
Is like I said previously bring your own truth social that kind of thing
It's like that will still be the case and that is no different to the way it has always been in the past for
Since the beginning of human existence, so where there was more than one person there was politics and there were people believing something different
So I I don't know but in any case we get a little bit off topic here
I do want to just quickly circle back to the whole artist suing on AI image generators because
That's something that really does annoy me
when people put content out on the internet doesn't matter what it is whether it's a written word and
and so on. If it's freely available, that's one thing. But if it's something that you've put out there,
like the one I was thinking of is Shutterstock, for example. I'll put stock photos out there,
but they'll have the Shutterstock logo on it. It's like, well, you want the version of that,
the raw photo of that without the watermark on it, you're going to pay for that. And it's like,
that's part of their business model, low res watermark stuff. But if that gets fed into an AI,
then that is not fair use. And that should be prosecutable. It's that simple. So if you're
If you're an artist and you put stuff out there, you know, it's funny because some of the photographers that are on photography forums will say, I never watermark my images.
So I started watermarking my photos when I took them and put them on tech distortion when I started my photography thing.
And I got some quite scathing feedback at the time from a few people looking at it saying, you're ruining your image by putting your watermark on it.
And I'm like, okay.
And they're like, oh, we only ever publish our images without a watermark on them.
And I'm like, yeah, but does that not imply that then anyone can take and use my
picture? I don't want them to take and use my picture without permission.
And so anyway, I sort of stopped doing it.
But now this whole AI sucking in millions of photos and doing the, you know,
creating images from them makes me reconsider that policy.
Yeah. And the good news is, well, apparently the AI isn't smart enough to try to get rid of the watermark either,
because that's how I think they found out about some of the stock images that
were getting sucked into the AI was because it was reproducing the watermark.
Yeah, exactly.
But yeah, so I feel like it is absolutely fair and reasonable for anyone who has
any content that is paid for content and you cannot, you know, and the usage terms
of it should be a new entry may be used for AI, yada, yada, yada, ingestion, or,
you know, training tool sets and what have you like that should now become
a new license condition.
And it already is, I imagine, on some license agreements.
And unless you explicitly opt into that,
then you can sue any company.
You should be able to, anyhow,
to sue any company that's using that information
against your usage agreement.
And honestly, I cannot wait to see some of these tool sets
and tools be destroyed by it,
because frankly, they just sucked in
everything from the internet thinking that was fair use,
and it just isn't.
We get mad at credit companies,
and, you know, all these companies that suck in our data supposedly for our good, for how
society functions, without our permission, without our knowledge, we don't know exactly
what they have, and then we get mad about that, but then these guys turn around and
just suck up everybody's stuff without permission or attribution or even recognition of the
fact that they're doing it, and that's just wrong.
It's like, you know, I wouldn't say it's hypocritical, because I don't know how they feel about how
their information is used personally, but yeah, it's just wrong.
And I think I agree with you completely about it should be an opt-in thing, and even there
should be multiple levels, like opt-in no attribution necessary, use as will, opt-in
attribution required, or this is mine, I don't want it used as inputs for your AI.
You know, there has to be a right on the artist's end to specify that, because you're right,
People are putting work out there, but that doesn't mean that they want it to be used. However
There has to be a way for people to have control over their own art
I know some people who go extremism and they're like, well, everything should be open for everybody. That's not quite true
I don't believe that's true. I think humans should be allowed to have control over their artwork
Yeah, I mean you've got basically three options one don't create art. That's that's the simplest option. Just don't do it
The second option is create art and give it freely to anyone who wants it at any time
And then the third option is create art and sell it.
So how you choose to sell it is the,
sort of for me is the debate.
So if you put it out there with a sample
and say, here's my low res sample
with a watermark on it for example,
the license agreement will say,
well, I'm gonna sell this
and these are the conditions and so on.
You can't just take my image and then use it.
If you want, you have to pay for it.
And then when you pay for it,
that is a license subject to those conditions.
And it might be, you can use it in a magazine.
You can use it, magazine's a still thing.
You can use it on a website.
You can use it for whatever you want.
But I doubt very much whether many licenses would say,
yeah, you can feed that into an AI model,
but that's the thing that should be coming.
Anyone that says that you should just create art free
for the world and then anyone can use it,
I think that that is a massive oversimplification.
If you take out like,
'cause ultimately there is art for art's sake
and I wanna create art and put it out there.
Well, that's your choice if that's what you wanna do.
But there are lots of artists that put art out there
and that is the way that they survive.
They don't survive based on, you know, people saying,
"Oh, hey man, painting looks great."
And it's like, "Yeah, but you know, I have no money.
Now I'm going to die because I have no food
and so on and so forth."
So you could probably argue that, you know,
that's probably not fair
'cause that person put that energy and effort in.
Some would say, "Oh, we should get a real job,"
and air quotes.
Great, go do a real job.
And then no one will create art.
So the reality is that art is something that,
when I started, and this is getting really a bit off,
maybe a bit off tangent,
But I never really used to understand art or appreciate art.
And I've got an engineer's mind in a lot of ways.
But the older I've gotten, and as you point out,
getting into photography is just one example,
but I've come to start appreciating art in different forms.
And it's something that honestly,
it lends meaning and value, I think, to our lives.
And whether that's music, whether that's painting,
whether it's photography,
that form of unique self-expression.
And it almost feels a little bit like a travesty
to sort of trivialize it with an AI and say, well, you know, show me a picture of a field
with a person standing in it. And it's like, that is not adding value to anything or anyone.
It just, it feels just terribly wrong in any way. And that is the touchy feely non-engineer
argument, I guess.
No, but that's what we are. We're touchy feely humans. And we can get a sense of an emotion
about that scene based on all kinds of intangible factors, based on our own history, based on
our visual preferences, based on things that have happened to us in the past.
Like when you just eating a specific meal with people and smelling that food can bring
back memories.
That's what we are, and AI is never going to have that.
And I think art does play an important role, and good things happen when people are allowed
to create art that inspires and motivates people, and bad things happen when people
feel like they can't create that art or they feel stifled. I just, yeah, it's undervalued
and it's the type of thing that everybody wants to consume but nobody wants to pay for.
And I feel the same way when I see people producing a free piece of software and some
dude rolls up with a huge laundry list of requests and says "when are these going
to be available?" and it's like, uhhh, could you be a little bit less of a jerk about the
fact that this guy's doing all this work for free?
Well, I mean, in that case, if something is freely open I'll ask the question and say
"Hey, are you looking towards this feature and that feature?"
You generally get a pretty straight answer, especially from single developer apps.
But when it comes to something like, "I'd pay for this feature, and I would pay for this feature," whatever else,
then I'd just have to wait until there's a developer who's prepared to do that, and then I'll pay them.
And that's the beauty of having both open source and paid apps.
Yeah, and fair game to saying, "Hey, I would be really interested in the software being able to do this,"
but then to roll up and say, "By the way, can you publish your timeline for making that happen?"
That's where I draw the line.
Yeah, OK, that's fair.
But one more thing I just think we should probably
discuss as well is all this.
Well, us crapping on AI, to be honest, and machine learning.
It's not all bad.
I mean, there are some good uses of of machine learning.
And one of the ones that I have heard you mentioned a few times now is is Whisper.
And I know very little about this.
It's on my to-do list to dig into.
But you've been using that for a little while.
Can you, you want to talk a little bit about that?
'Cause I'd love to know actually.
Yeah, and the funny thing is,
is that when I was listening to that podcast,
Don't Fall for the AI Hype episode
of Tech Won't Save Us with Timnit,
she specifically mentioned open AI
because she has some real problems
with the philosophies of the founders
and fair game to her because I think she's right.
But open AI does have a tool that I find quite useful
and it's called Whisper.
And it's a Python-based audio transcription application.
And basically what it does is it takes audio files
and analyzes them and spits out a transcript for you.
And somebody created a C and C++ port of that,
and it is also optimized for Apple Silicon.
So I've been running that and doing tests with it.
And I found that it's good enough for me,
It does a pretty good job, and I found that it does a good enough job for me that I think
I can create usable transcripts for friends with brews that I can put up on the site.
I haven't figured out yet if I'm going to go so far as to denote speakers of each sentence
and so forth, I may, but the bottom line is I think I can come up with a workflow that
doesn't take me too much time to massage that transcript into something usable, and that
way it'll give people something searchable.
And also, hey, just for us, we can also search and say, "How much detail did we go into on
this topic before on the podcast?"
And, you know, transcripts are never a bad option to give people if you can.
And I think, you know, there's other podcasters that I know are using this as well, experimenting
with it to see how it will work.
And this is the type of thing where I think AI can be positive because I don't really
see any downsides to taking my own audio and creating a transcript of it.
I'm not stealing work from anybody.
Really what I'm doing is trying to make my podcast more accessible to people.
Yeah, absolutely.
So this is the type of thing where I'm positive about it.
And regardless of what OpenAI as a company is doing in general,
the Whisper product is something that's pretty cool.
And it's basically just out there on GitHub for people to use.
So I am going to have a crack at that at some point in the next couple of weeks.
I've had a few things going on with the 50th episode celebrations of causality.
I've been trying to get a whole bunch of things done before that.
and that's part of that sort of thing with the t-shirts and all that other stuff that I've been doing and
Q&A stuff and all that stuff
but it's been on my list for a couple weeks and I'm like I really want to have a crack at this because the way
I do my sound bites, sound bites, my goodness, sorry, transcripts, is that I will, I up, okay, I
started doing the parallel publish to YouTube a few years ago because it was a Libsyn feature where you could just say, you know
YouTube as an output, it would go through and encode a static image with the entire video, the entire audio
but as a video file and then it would upload it to YouTube to your account and publish it for you.
And so I did this for causality and just just for the heck of it to see if it would make a difference.
And then after a while I started to see, I was picking up a couple of patrons,
I said "Oh, we found you via YouTube." I'm like, okay, so this is probably worth doing but it's not a huge
huge downloads or you know a huge section of the market, but it's still better than not doing it.
The side effect of doing that, and since now I now export using Ferrite into a video and then upload it manually because I get more control over it.
Anyway, so when you do that it automatically generates, YouTube generates its own SRT and files that you can then download once it auto-translates it for you.
And these files, like they're generally okay, but they do need a lot of work and I'm quite the perfectionist so I don't like putting up stuff that's rubbish.
So what I've done is I've also invested another bit of software for the Mac called
Subtitle Studio and I go in and I load the video and then I load the the file the
Subtitles transcript and I go through and I make sure that everything does line up with the correct time and date stamps
I've only done that for causality
I haven't done it for a multi-person show
But the transcripts that I've got have been done via the YouTube system whatever they use in the back end, right?
But I really want to try whisper to see if it makes if see if it's better because every time it makes a mistake
Going through and fixing that is a is a pain in the butt
it just takes time and it discourages me from doing transcripts at all because
You know if I wasn't a perfectionist, maybe that'd be fine, you know, just put up there and say hey
It's only gonna be 90% and my last name will be spelt chiggily or something like that
And who cares, you know and it'll say person to when I mean went percent or be stupid stuff like that
But I mean if whisper is better then maybe that's a better option
Yeah, and the good news is like with some of the when I was playing with the transcripts
I quickly came up with some regexes for some common things and a
couple other little things that I can run it through every time and get rid of some of the problems and even with
Formatting it it helped me
Format it a little bit. I'll have to see how well that works over time
But yeah, the good news is you can do stuff like that for common things, but you did answer a question
I had I know that YouTube is generating those
Transcuh, those captions now and I was really curious as to whether or not people could get their hands on them
So that's that's actually really cool. That's pretty cool. Yeah, I've been doing it now for a little while
I even went back through older ones, older episodes and when I realized you could access it and download it and it was um
It's actually not that hard. Uh, but like I said the idea of doing rejects is for common problems
that might help a little bit but you know the quality of it's not necessarily the best but
The fact that I can do that and it's like not that much extra effort is great.
It's funny you know because some like the whole podcasting 2.0 movement like I've got where I
have got transcripts you can download them as an individual file at the site or you can have them
embedded and they'll actually show up in sync with the audio if you're listening in a podcasting 2.0
compliant application like Cast-O-Matic or Podverse or something like that will show the
transcript coming up at the exact moment the words are spoken just like it shouldn't as if it was
was closed captions on TV, which is really cool.
But the amount of effort it takes to get to that point is huge.
And I don't want to put out-I don't want to put rubbish out there.
So I-yeah.
So I'll give this a shot, and I'll see what it's like,
and I'll report back.
I'll let you know how it goes.
Sounds good, yeah.
By the way, at some point in time, I do want to talk to you about Podcasting 2.0.
I actually meant to a long time ago.
Oh, sure.
And then--
Yeah.
I didn't even think of it when I set this up for some reason.
One interesting thing I did find Whisper to be 100% adequate for
is I have a website called syracusases.com,
and I just take little tiny clips of things
from John Syracusa who comes up with lovable,
very notable quotes, he's a very quotable guy.
And so I'll just post little clips
from various different podcasts that he's on, real short.
I try to make sure, send everybody his work.
I'm not trying to profit or benefit off John Syracusa.
It's just that something is a fan that I do 'cause it's fun.
But Whisper is amazing for generating
the little transcripts that I publish with each episode of that.
It just generally I don't have to change anything.
It just pumps it right out.
So if it's a clip where Marco or Casey or some other host of a podcast
is on also says something, then, yeah, I have to split it and add names and so forth.
But they're so short anyway.
We're talking like 30 second to minute and a half clips that it doesn't matter.
But Whisper will just generate those for me now, whereas I used to have to
listen to them, play them back and type it out.
So I don't even have to do that anymore.
You want to know something funny?
I didn't, this is just, I came across that in my timeline and
it never clicked that the Syracuse or says website was done by you.
It just, I'm like, I knew there was a site Syracuse that says, I'm like, wow,
someone's really a big Syracuse fan and I never dug into it. And it's like,
oh wow, that's your site? Oh, how cool is this?
Well, it's funny because I got,
I finally got Peter to listen to ATP because a lot of his Apple related
questions, I was like, dude, just start listening to ATP as a base primer.
Just start listening to it.
And he and I would laugh so much about some of the things that Sir Kiuso would say.
And I don't know, we must haveIt must have been on a Friends with Brews where we had been
drinking beer or something where we came up with the idea.
But anyway, it's still fun to do.
Oh, that's awesome.
I think that's fantastic.
And a part of me, to be honest, I'm waiting until someone out there is a big enough fan of my
work that they do what Chidgey says, because then I know I've made it.
Until then, though, it's okay.
I'll just keep waiting.
Challenge accepted.
That's not a hint.
That's not a hint, by the way.
It has to be organic, because if it's not organic, then that does not qualify.
So you are now excluded, as are any of the listeners, from ever creating such a thing,
because that would be like me soliciting that.
So no, you can't do that.
But anyway.
I was going to say Vic will do it, but I don't know what year he'll get started on that.
Oh, that's harsh.
Yes, good question.
Twenty-something.
Anyhow, it's all good.
Ah, Vic's awesome.
But never mind that.
He is.
And he knows I'm teasing him. I know he is listening. That's why I said that. We'll get VicGPT on it.
Yeah, those deep fake things. That's another thing. Yeah.
So, um, someone deep faked an interview with Adam Curry because they kept inviting him on their podcast and he kept not going on their podcast.
So they just did a deep fake interview with him.
Oh my God, that's hilarious.
It was so hilarious. I mean...
I got to find that now. That is funny.
I'll see if I can find the link for you. That'sYeah, it's wrong.
That's funny.
All right, John. Well, I have to go get in a car and drive around a
bunch of 16-year-old girls because my daughter's having a birthday party event today.
That sounds like a special kind of pain potentially.
So hopefully they are.
Yeah, one 16-year-old girl on their own is fine.
Two isgets louder.
Three, it'sit's exponential.
And then there's the giggling and then there's theyes.
So anyway, enjoy that.
Enjoy that.
I think it'll be better than it could be because the good news is that my daughter is a very good human for reasons
That are totally unconnected with being my daughter. She just is okay. I'm not taking credit
So she has good friends. I've liked all of her friends that I've met
So I don't think it'll be as bad as it could be. But yeah, it's still it's still something I gotta do
Now it's all good, man. All good. All good. I appreciate you being here
It was so good to talk to you again after so long
What would you like to point people to these days for how to find you and how to enjoy more of your?
accent your untoppable
voice
Dear well Adam Curry
Said that I have very nice pipes and for a second there
I thought he was talking about my legs because that's some people talk today
That's pipes of legs and I'm like what no what no oh you mean my voice. Oh, yeah, right cheers. Thanks Adam
That's very nice coming from the pod father, but anyway oh
It was a weird moment anyhow sorry right you can reach me at at Chiji C H I D G E Y at
engineered dot space that's where I hang out on the Fedeverse and
My my projects my my passion project
I guess you could call it is the engineered network and that's engineered dot network as in the full word
And you'll find podcasts there like pragmatic and and causality is the other big one
So yeah, if you want to hear more of me then check them out
Yeah, and I'm sure that most of the people listening to this do or have, and it would
be more likely to be listening to those than this, but if you're not, for some reason,
do – I love Causality, by the way.
It's just a fascinating show.
And there's so many episodes I listen to and you're just going, "No, no, no, no,
why?"
I know.
The human condition.
Yeah, the funny thing about Causality is that I started it years ago back in 2015, and I wasn't sure anyone was going to like it, because I thought, nah, this will be too geeky, this...
Because I said at the beginning, I don't... I don't... I want to do... analyze disasters, but from an engineering point of view. So no hype, no...
No, uh, character voices, no fake explosion sounds, none of that. I just want to keep it to... This is the sequence of events, this is what happened.
These are the relevant bits of information and this is how they could have actually stopped it from happening
Because to me that's useful like having a bunch of people in a dramatization going
Oh, it's gonna blow up and all sort of stuff. It's like that doesn't help you that doesn't help anybody
It's just like it's it's a poor form of entertainment and I don't even know if it's in good taste
but the reality is that it's tended to be very very popular in the end and it's got a it's got a
It's not a at its peak
Pragmatic was probably five times the size in terms of downloads that causality is today
But the truth is that I think the fans of causality are hardcore
Lifelong fans. I've never had anyone say that they've stopped listening in disgust like like I got with pragmatic several times believe me
You know when I get some fact wrong, but on causality I've had nothing but positive feedback on it and
It's it's a it's a pleasure to make it
I just wish I had more time to make more episodes, but yeah, I'm glad you like it. Thank you
It's very nice for you